[Musique]
lundi de septembre ce sont trente six
mille sept cents collégiens haut rhinois
qui reprenait le chemin de l'école après
les vacances d'été pour le conseil
départemental qui a la gestion des 57
collèges publics du département
cette rentrée c'est toujours un temps
fort l'occasion de présenter les grandes
orientations pour l'année à venir
depuis deux ans petit prêt pour la
réussite éducative de tous du
département monte en puissance
cinq cents millions d'euros seront
investis sur 10 ans dans la jeunesse
prêt pour la rentrée au conseil
départemental
ça veut dire beaucoup de travaux
beaucoup de travaux pour mettre aux
collégiens pour permettre aussi aux
enseignants de travailler dans les
meilleures conditions possibles
cette année ce sont près de 47 millions
de travaux que le conseil départemental
a fait dans les différents collèges haut
rhinois et ce sont 170 millions 200
millions d'euros dans les huit
prochaines années qui sont prévues pour
de l'investissement
de quoi assurer aux jeunes haut-rhinois
d'étudier dans des collèges dernier cri
dans le département la population
augmente les rénovations suffisent
généralement à absorber le surcroît de
jeunes collégiens cependant dans
certains secteurs la croissance est
telle que le département va devoir
construire deux nouveaux collèges dans
le secteur de saint louis
la population se développe beaucoup la
population de jeunes et également à
mulhouse
ça veut dire que nous avons en projet
deux nouveaux collèges un collège à
kembs avec pour échéance 2024 ayant
collége à mulhouse avec pour échéance
voilà donc deux nouveaux projets des
projets neufs aux côtés de tous les
projets de rénovation des collèges comme
aussi commis ici à wintzenheim à
wintzenheim les travaux ont commencé il
ya trois ans et vont se poursuivre
jusqu'à fin 2022
objectif moderniser le collège et
améliorer l'accueil des élèves
on s'occupe finalement de la
redistribution reconfiguration de tous
les espaces intérieurs absolument tous
pour pouvoir fonctionner de façon plus
rationnelle en regroupant l'épaule par
exemple les pôle pédagogique et la vie
scolaire les de l'infirmerie
voilà également permettre de meilleurs
accès que tout soit davantage en
conformité pour l'accueil également des
personnes à mobilité réduite tout en
permettant une meilleure performance
matériel qu'en ce qui concerne les
outils diversifiée mais également dans
les nouvelles technologies pour
permettre aux enseignants d'être
davantage en phase avec les exigences
une pédagogie moderne motiver davantage
des élèves des tablettes numériques dans
les classes de collège
voilà quelques années que le dispositif
est en test dans différents
établissements haut rhinois cette année
ce sont 650 une nouvelle tablette qui
vont rejoindre les collèges dans le
cadre 17 projets plus globalement c'est
l'ensemble des équipements numériques
des collèges qui vont être mis à niveau
à partir de cette année il ya un très
gros investissement puisque nous avons
un plan numérique sur les trois quatre
ans qui viennent de 10 millions d'euros
donc c'est notre rôle aussi au niveau du
département d'améliorer les choses pour
que les élèves soient prêts dans le
cadre du numérique pour aller entre
autres au guichet où nous avons des
ordinateurs tout est démérité et donc
c'est important que nos collèges soit
prêt pour ce passage du collège au lycée
dans le haut rhin cette rentrée était
l'occasion de mettre en avant
l'enseignement bilingue à l'heure
actuelle trois mille cinq cents
collégiens sur trente six mille suivent
un cursus en français et en allemand
un chiffre que le conseil départemental
aimerait voir grimper dans les
prochaines années en s'appuyant sur une
nouvelle compétence de la collectivité
européenne d'alsace on sait qu'ils les
difficultés que rencontrent l'éducation
nationale aujourd'hui pour recruter des
enseignants en langue allemande
donc la collectivité européenne d'alsace
va recruter des intervenants ce sera par
exemple des étudiants allemands en fin
d'études
ce sera par exemple aussi des cadres
d'entreprises notamment d'entreprises
allemands
saviola va nous permettre de développer
l'enseignement de l'allemand de la
maternelle jusqu'au baccalauréat mais
aussi dans le cadre périscolaire
l'idée c'est aux côtés de l'éducation
nationale et en complément de ce que
fait l'éducation nationale de motiver
les jeunes alsaciens à apprendre
l'allemand et nous allons construire peu
à peu aux côtés de l'éducation nationale
ces actions pour développer le
bilinguisme pour cette rentrée 2010 9 un
seul intervenant a été recruté à neuf
brisach pour mener l'expérimentation
mais le conseil départemental espère
bien pouvoir lancer le dispositif avant
même le début officiel de la
collectivité européenne d'alsace oui en
effet derrière cet enjeu éducatif
d'importants enjeux économiques
c'est important le bilinguisme et le
développement du bilinguisme parce que
ce sont des emplois pour les jeunes
alsaciens dans les 15 années qui
viennent ce sont trente mille emplois
pour un jeune alsacien qui sera bilingue
il y a deux ans un seul collège
organisait une journée citoyenne l'année
dernière ils étaient une dizaine au
conseil départemental
on espère qu'une majorité des 57
collèges du département se prêteront à
l'exercice
nous avons cette année on a on a à peu
près une dizaine de journées citoyennes
qui ont lieu qui se font avait à
l'intérieur du collège avec des aides
extérieures voir un travail avec des
communes avec nos services et qui
sensibilise un peu des enfants et qui
les responsabilise et ça fonctionne très
bien et les parents d'élèves participent
eux aussi très souvent à ces journées là
au delà des journées citoyennes c'est
l'engagement des jeunes que l'on
souhaite développer ainsi en 2019 le
conseil départemental lance un appel à
projets objectif soutenir des
initiatives visant à promouvoir la
citoyenneté la solidarité le respect de
l'environnement l'engagement citoyen
c'est le respect de l'autre c'est la
tolérance s'est donné du temps pour les
autres et c'est aussi mieux connaître la
religion de l'autre et là nous avons
déployé et amplifié depuis deux ans de
nombreuses actions pour les collégiens
puisque les collégiens d'aujourd'hui
sont les citoyens de demain
autant d'initiatives que nous ne
manquerons pas de vous relater tout au
long de l'année scolaire
bonne rentrée à tous les collégiens